what are your thoughts about kids and
screens the issue is not screens the
issue is hypocrisy you can't talk about
screens all day and say how shitty they
are and then when you have your friend
over and the kids are making noise you
throw the iPad at them if you don't like
Tick Tock take it off your kids iPad if
you don't want them to be on screens
take it away it's a boring thing to
watch people blame screens I think it's
time to start blaming ourselves we are
getting better and better and better and
better at pointing fingers it's this
Tech company's fault it's this app's
fault it's this influencer's fault we've
gotten so good at blaming absolutely
everything but ourselves the second you
blame yourself well then you can start
controlling the outcome you want I think
screens are incredibly positive and
Incredibly negative the same way I feel
about everything I just don't understand
why parents continue to blame technology
instead of themselves